the editor-in-chief of germany's
best-selling newspaper built has been
removed from his post over revelations
of misconduct the publishing company
axel springer said julian reichelt would
be axed from the helm with immediate
effects the 41 year old was suspended
earlier this year as part of a company
probe into his management style and
later reinstated his sacking comes after
a new york times investigation uncovered
fresh allegations against him including
an affair with a trainee and financial
impropriety
and for more on this let's bring in our
political correspondent jared reed good
morning to you jared what is he
specifically accused of
this time around that made the company
act now
hi christine well julian reichelt is
accused of professional and sexual
misconduct of having an affair
specifically with a trainee who he then
promoted and more generally a pattern of
seeking out younger women in the company
where he worked women whose careers he
essentially controlled having affairs
with them and then sidelining
or uh firing them
jared is is this only about one man's
personal misconduct or is it a sign uh
for a problematic corporate culture at
build or perhaps even axel springer as
as a whole
it's probably a bit of both we have to
remember that
these claims that have been reported on
about julian reichelt aren't really new
uh earlier this year axel springer the
the company that owns the build
newspaper
suspended him for 12 days after
revelations about his management style
they conducted an investigation and 12
days later ruled that there was nothing
to see there and they they uh reinstated
him so it appears that it's taken an
expose from the new york times over the
weekend to really push the company into
action axel springer itself has released
a statement saying it's gained new
information about yulia and but as i say
a lot of what's reported isn't new so
it's hard to know what um the
information could have been this is a
really big story in germany but if you
were to read the build newspaper this
morning you just see a small item on
page three about it about a change in
the management so the newspaper itself
is is keeping quite tight-lipped
and jared why would it be the new york
times why was this uncovered by the new
york times
well axel springer the parent company of
build has been on somewhat of a spending
spree it's seeking to become a major
player globally in digital publishing
and most recently it bought the
political journalism company politico so
it really has um global ambitions beyond
germany and europe so as it does seek to
expand
it's inviting more scrutiny from
particularly the english-speaking world
and the biggest newspaper in the world
the new york times about its uh guest
management style and workplace culture
all right that's dw's jared reed thanks
for that jared